Voler, flotter en apesanteur,
le dirigeable a conquis le ciel,
et transformé la vision
de l'homme sur le monde.
Arme de guerre redoutable en 14-18,
puis luxueux paquebot
des airs dans les années 30,
il assure les premières
traversées de l'Atlantique.
Et s'impose à l'époque comme
le transport aérien de prédilection.
Le succès est assuré, mais un drame
va tout remettre en cause.
Il a pris feu ! C'est la chute !
C'est terrible ! Mon dieu !
Éloignez-vous s'il vous plait.
Le 6 mai 1937, le Zeppelin s'écrase
à New York dans un nuage de fumée,
bouleversant à jamais
son avenir prometteur.
La conséquence de ce malheur,
ce fut la fin des dirigeables.
Mais aujourd'hui, les nouvelles
technologies pourraient rendre au ballon,
sa notoriété.
Mission de surveillance,
alternative écologique,
transport d'hôpitaux dans des pays
en guerre et même tourisme de luxe,
le géant des airs va-t-il enfin
renaître de ses cendres ?
Le dirigeable est une fantastique
machine à rêver.
Je crois que l'on ne peut pas mieux
voyager que dans un dirigeable.
Ces machines sont extraordinaires,
peuvent réaliser des missions
qu'aucune autre machine ne peut faire.
On y est maintenant,
on est complètement dedans.
Je crois que le XXIᵉ siècle sera
le siècle du dirigeable. C'est évident.
Historiens, scientifiques et ingénieurs
promettent son grand retour.
Le dirigeable sera-t-il la star
du ciel de demain ?
En France, à Écausseville,
dans ce hangar normand,
vestige de la grande époque
de l'aérostation,
on invente les dirigeables du futur.
Jean-pierre David est aéronaute.
Il a imaginé ce ballon miniature,
l'aéroplume.
Ce ballon est entièrement gonflé
à l'hélium, un gaz plus léger que l'air,
utilisé dans tous les dirigeables
et qui va lui permettre de s'envoler.
Peut-être le regazer un petit peu.
Là, j'ai remis de l'hélium
dans le ballon.
Il faut un mètre cube d'hélium
pour porter un kilo.
C'est l'équation de base
pour voler en ballon.
Là, si on considère le ballon qui
fait 150 mètres cubes de volume,
on sait que le pilote,
plus les ailes, plus le harnais,
plus le ventilateur, plus le lest
est égal à 150 kilos.
Le ballon, il est un peu gros pour moi,
je rajoute un petit peu de poids.
C'est sensible et précis.
C'est le principe de tous
les ballons dirigeables,
c'est de voler en équilibre dans l'air.
C'est assez sensible.
Je pousse un tout petit peu
sur mes doigts. Je ne suis pas mal.
Le ballon dirigeable, c'est l'avenir du transport
aérien puisqu'on est porté par la masse d'air.
On ne dépense aucune énergie pour
être en équilibre dans la masse d'air.
On utilise juste l'énergie pour se déplacer.
C'est parfaitement écologique.
C'est aussi l'école du minimum, le plus
petit ballon dirigeable possible,
c'est l'aéroplume, celui qui
est au dessus de mon dos.
C'est un formidable laboratoire,
pour étudier tout ce qu'on
a besoin de réapprendre,
pour pouvoir construire
des ballons plus gros.
Je suis pas mal là, j'ai bien
envie de partir voler maintenant.
Je vais faire mon décollage.
Allez, top décollage !
Trop dingue !
C'est l'avenir du ballon dirigeable.
Un jour, chacun aura
sa bulle d'hélium dans le dos.
Pourquoi ne pas imaginer qu'on soit tous en
train de voler avec des mini ballons dirigeables.
Oui, c'est un très beau projet d'avenir.
Le dirigeable est devant nous.
Le dirigeable,
une invention tournée vers l'avenir,
qui a largement fait
ses preuves dans le passé.
Tout commence il y a plus de 200 ans.
Les hommes rêvaient déjà
de voler, mais à l'époque,
on ne connaît pas encore les vertus de l'hélium.
En 1783, les frères Montgolfier
font une découverte surprenante.
Il est possible de gonfler un ballon avec
de l'air chaud, plus léger que l'air froid.
Quelques semaines plus tard, ce sont
2 autres aventuriers qui vont l'expérimenter,
et réaliser le premier vol de l'histoire,
comme le raconte Philippe Tixier,
spécialiste de l'histoire
des dirigeables.
Le 21 novembre 1783 se produit
un événement extraordinaire.
Pilâtre de Rozier
et le Marquis d'Arlandes,
s'envolent à bord d'une montgolfière.
L'homme vole pour
la première fois librement.
Le plus vieux rêve de l'homme
est enfin accompli.
Dix jours plus tard,
un autre ballon à hydrogène cette fois,
s'envole de l'esplanade
des Tuileries, dans Paris,
C'est Charles, un très grand physicien
de l'époque, qui a conçu ce ballon à gaz.
Il y a 600000 personnes qui ont
assisté à ce deuxième événement,
la moitié de la population de Paris.
Cet événement a eu un retentissement
mondial extraordinaire.
Lavoisier, le grand chimiste, dit :
"Ce qui s'est passé est absolument
extraordinaire, historique.
Ça ouvre des perspectives
prodigieuses. Et maintenant,
il faut faire des ballons dirigeables."
Le mot est né.
La compétition est lancée.
On se rêve aéronaute,
on imagine des ballons de toutes
sortes et même à rames.
Très vite, les inventeurs comprennent
qu'il faut modifier la forme des ballons.
D'abord circulaires, elles s'allongent
pour faciliter la pénétration dans l'air.
Mais il faut attendre la machine
à vapeur et Henri Giffard,
en 1852 pour maîtriser la propulsion
et lutter contre le vent.
On fantasme alors sur des villes
flottantes dans les airs,
des bus et des taxis volants.
C'est la grande époque de la Ballonmania.
Une période riche en innovations,
comme l'explique Jürgen Bleibler,
historien du musée Zeppelin.
En 1884, deux officiers,
Charles Renard et Krebs,
construisent la "France".
Un dirigeable qui était équipé
de moteurs électriques plus légers.
Ce fut réellement le premier dirigeable
car on pouvait le piloter.
Pour preuve, il a réussi le premier circuit
fermé en partant d'un point de départ,
et en retournant
à ce même point de départ.
Après Charles Renard, d'autres
inventeurs poursuivent le rêve.
Santos-Dumont, Clément-Bayard,
Edouard Surcouf.
Pendant près d'un siècle, c'est la France
qui domine cette conquête du ciel.
Jusqu'à ce que, de l'autre
côté du Rhin, en Allemagne,
un certain comte Von Zeppelin,
ne fassent irruption dans ce monde
nouveau des dirigeables.
La France a toujours été la nation
leader en matière d'aéronautique,
en gros jusqu'à
la Première Guerre mondiale.
Ce sont des choses comme ça
qui ont inspiré le comte Zeppelin,
d'une manière extraordinaire.
Officier de l'armée
allemande et ingénieur,
le comte Zeppelin s'intéresse depuis
toujours au ballon et à l'idée de voler.
À l'âge de 62 ans,
il concrétise enfin sa passion.
Le comte Ferdinand Zeppelin alerte
le gouvernement allemand pour dire,
Attention, en France, il se passe des choses.
Ils sont en train de prendre un avantage,
une supériorité.
Il faut faire quelque chose.
Le gouvernement allemand
et les militaires ne comprennent pas.
Et le comte Zeppelin va financer
sur ses fonds propres, sur sa fortune,
la réalisation du premier dirigeable
rigide en Allemagne qui volera en 1900,
pour répondre à l'avance des Français.
Von Zeppelin voit grand, tout de suite.
C'est l'ère de l'aluminium,
matériel nouveau, ultra léger,
idéal pour mener la guerre au kilo.
Ce qui lui permet de construire un ballon
3 fois plus grand que tous ses prédécesseurs.
Le 2 juillet 1900, au dessus
du lac de Constance,
à la frontière suisse-allemande,
le LZ 1 prend son envol.
L'aéronaute Pierre Chabert décrypte
l'équation qui a permis une telle prouesse.
La loi est très simple en physique.
Un mètre cube d'hélium, un kilo.
L'hydrogène, c'est à peu près pareil.
Il s'est dit, il suffit de faire très gros
et on porte très lourd. Il avait raison.
Il fallait quand même oser monter
en l'air avec ce dirigeable.
C'était une avancée comparable
à ce que fut dans les années 60,
la navigation spatiale.
Une avancée vers quelque chose
de totalement inconnu.
Aux commandes du dirigeable
de 128 mètres de long,
le comte Von Zeppelin lui-même.
Un visionnaire porté par ses rêves,
comme le décrit son descendant,
Wolfgang von Zeppelin.
Le comte Zeppelin était
incroyablement optimiste.
C'était presque imprudent,
il faut le dire.
Il imaginait même déjà
des voyages transocéaniques,
alors qu'il manquait encore beaucoup
de choses et de progrès à réaliser.
On ne vole encore que quelques heures
et à 20 km/h seulement.
Mais Von Zeppelin croit à sa formule.
Dès lors, deux grandes familles de
dirigeables se développent parallèlement.
Les souples et les rigides.
À l'intérieur des ballons
dirigeables souples,
on trouve un ballonnet
qui va être rempli d'air,
et qui va compenser la dilatation
et la rétractation du gaz porteur,
de l'hélium ou de l'hydrogène.
Sur les ballons dirigeables très allongés,
le ballon est assez long,
on va avoir un ballonnet
à l'avant et à l'arrière,
qui va être rempli d'air
et qui va compenser,
la dilatation et la rétractation
du gaz porteur,
Le pilote peut jouer
sur les deux ballonnets,
pour régler l'assiette de son ballon.
Pour que le dirigeable descende,
il faut injecter de l'air
dans le ballonnet à l'avant.
Étant plus lourd que l'hélium,
l'air permet au nez de l'aéronef,
de piquer vers le bas.
Sur le rigide,
c'est un autre principe.
L'hélium ou l'hydrogène est enfermé,
dans plusieurs cellules à l'intérieur
du ballon, tout au long du ballon.
On laisse de la place pour la dilatation
de la rétractation du gaz,
à l'intérieur de la carène rigide.
Et là, ça se gère tout seul.
Composé de toiles
et d'une structure d'aluminium,
la carène protège tous les ballons
d'hélium qui se dilatent avec l'altitude.
Pour manœuvrer un dirigeable
à structure rigide,
les pilotes utilisent alors des moteurs
situés à l'avant et à l'arrière.
Les dirigeables, qu'ils soient
souples ou rigides,
révolutionnent le début du XXᵉ siècle.
Ils sont utilisés par les armées
allemandes et françaises,
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale.
Ils sont de plus en plus perfectionnés.
En 1914, un Zeppelin peut parcourir
une distance de 1500 km.
Quatre ans plus tard, sa capacité de vol lui
permet de franchir le seuil des 10 000 km.
Désormais, le monde est à portée de ballon.
Et c'est ce dirigeable
britannique, le R34,
piloté par le major George Herbert Scott,
qui va marquer à jamais l'histoire
de l'aéronautique.
Le premier appareil volant
qui a traversé l'Atlantique,
c'est un dirigeable en 1919.
Il a traversé l'Atlantique,
d'Angleterre à New York,
avec 30 personnes à bord,
et une semaine après,
il a fait le trajet inverse,
Huit ans avant Lindbergh.
Et ça, on l'a oublié.
Un exploit qui marque le début
de l'âge d'or du dirigeable.
Celui des premiers
voyages transatlantiques.
La presse surnomme ces nouvelles
machines volantes,
les vaisseaux du ciel.
Dans les années 20 et 30, le monde
se regarde à travers la fenêtre d'un zeppelin.
Vous devez imaginez que subitement,
les continents se sont rapprochés.
C'était une révolution immense du trafic.
Un changement que confirme
Barbara Waibel,
la directrice des Archives Zeppelin.
Quand on imagine qu'un bateau avait besoin
de 5 à 6 jours pour aller en Amérique,
et pour l'Amérique du Sud, il fallait
3 semaines alors qu'avec un dirigeable,
3 jours suffisaient.
C'était un gain de temps énorme.
Nous sommes maintenant en 1936.
Le baron von Zeppelin n'est plus de ce monde,
mais sa marque s'est imposée dans le ciel.
C'est Hugo Eckener, son fidèle lieutenant,
qui dirige désormais la firme.
Et cette année là, le 129ᵉ Zeppelin
s'apprête à sortir de l'usine bavaroise,
de Friedrichshafen.
L'Hindenburg, le plus grand
aéronef jamais construit par l'homme.
Un géant de 245 mètres capable
de franchir les océans,
et de transporter une cinquantaine
de passagers et autant d'hommes d'équipage.
Il vole à 100 km/h.
Un géant à la pointe de la technologie,
dont le parti nazi au pouvoir,
se sert pour sa propagande.
Durant les Jeux Olympiques De 1936
qui se déroulent à Berlin,
L'Hindenburg parade au dessus du stade,
arborant la croix gammée.
L'Hindenburg n'a pu être terminé
que sous le régime des nazis,
qui venait de prendre le pouvoir.
Et eux, ils ont toujours
été doués, je dirais,
pour identifier les thèmes qu'ils
pouvaient exploiter pour leur propagande.
Ils ont alors alloué un crédit
de 3 millions de mark de l'époque,
pour prendre des parts
dans la nouvelle compagnie.
En contrepartie, les dirigeables
devaient servir leur propagande.
C'était même indiqué
dans le règlement officiel.
Chaque dirigeable en Allemagne
devait porter sur son empennage,
la croix gammée.
Pour la petite histoire, le Hindenburg
devait être gonflé à l'hélium,
et les Américains ont voté une loi,
pour interdire la vente
d'hélium aux Allemands,
parce que le Hindenburg
était utilisé par les nazis,
pour faire la promotion
du national socialisme.
C'est donc gonflé à l'hydrogène,
un gaz hautement inflammable,
que le plus gros aéronef
de tous les temps prend son envol.
Mais c'est aussi ce gaz
qui entrainera sa chute,
et l'accident le plus spectaculaire
de l'histoire des dirigeables.
L'Hindenburg va également marquer
l'histoire par sa technologie.
Il est trois fois plus grand que
l'Airbus A380 d'aujourd'hui,
presque aussi long que le Titanic,
mais il ne pèse que 250 tonnes
contre 50 000 pour le paquebot.
Son intérieur est entièrement pensé
pour le confort des passagers.
Vous aviez des salles immenses.
On voit des gens qui prennent
des repas dans des salles à manger.
Il y a des cabines, des salons.
Tout ça en vol.
C'était un confort.
C'était vraiment des paquebots de l'air.
La construction des dirigeables rigides
avant la Première Guerre mondiale,
et dans les années 20 et 30,
était une performance
technologique vraiment,
au seuil de ce qui était faisable.
En apparence, rien ne prédisait
le drame du 6 mai 1937.
Après trois jours de traversée,
parti d'Allemagne,
l'Hindenburg atteint New York.
C'est donc gonflé à l'hydrogène que
le plus gros aéronef de tous les temps,
survole la ville avec l'emblème
du régime nazi sur ses empennages.
À son bord, 99 personnes.
À l'extérieur, les amis et les
proches attendaient déjà leur invité,
qui étaient à bord du dirigeable.
On se faisait signe de la main.
Tout paraissait bien.
Il se remet à pleuvoir...
Le dirigeable est pratiquement
immobile maintenant.
Ils viennent de laisser tomber
des cordes d'amarrage hors du nez du navire.
Et puis tout d'un coup...
Il y a eu comme une détonation et une boule
de feu s'est propagée à l'intérieur,
tout le long du dirigeable.
Il a pris feu ! C'est la chute !
C'est terrible ! Mon dieu !
Éloignez-vous s'il vous plait !
Il s'écrase. C'est terrbile ! C'est
la pire des catastrophes du Monde !
Il tombe du ciel d'au moins 150 mètres...
C'est un accident terrible
pour l'humanité !
Tous les passagers hurlent...
On peut à peine respirer...
Je vous le dis, ils sont
tous en train de mourir !
Je vais devoir m'arrêter
parce que je perds la voix...
C'est la pire des choses
que j'ai vue de ma vie.
Les passagers, en grande partie,
ont étonnamment survécu,
justement parce qu'ils étaient
dans ce salon reproduit ici,
et ils ont pu s'échapper
par les fenêtres.
64 miraculés réchappent de l'enfer,
mais le bilan est lourd.
35 morts, pour la plupart
des membres de l'équipage.
HugoEckener, le patron de Zeppelin
à l'époque,
fait immédiatement le voyage aux États-Unis
pour enquêter, pour comprendre.
Et le capitaine qui est brûlé
mais qui survit,
Lui explique : "J'ai fais une bêtise.
j'ai viré trop fort,
j'étais pressé d'atterrir."
C'est le câble de la commande
qui a cassé et ce câble sous tension,
est venu percuter l'enveloppe,
a déchiré l'enveloppe.
Il a touché les éléments métalliques,
ça a fait une étincelle.
C'est cette étincelle qui a mis
le feu aux sacs d'hydrogène,
et tout s'est embrasé.
Les journalistes ont imaginé
que c'était une bombe,
un acte de terrorisme,
que quelqu'un avait tiré dessus.
On peut imaginer
toute sorte de choses.
Mais le témoignage du capitaine
de la machine, lui-même,
ça a beaucoup de valeur, bien sûr.
Il y a toujours de nouvelles théories,
des spéculations.
Mais ce qui est vrai,
c'est que personne ne sait exactement.
C'est terrible cette histoire, parce que,
la catastrophe ne serait pas arrivée
s'ils avaient eu l'hélium.
Ça, c'est vrai.
Cela a été un énorme traumatisme,
parce que la catastrophe du Hindenburg,
s'est passée devant les caméras.
La conséquence de ce malheur,
il faut le dire,
c'est que cela a signé
la fin des dirigeables.
On a tout de suite arrêté
le transport de passagers.
Et puis les ballons gonflés à l'hydrogène.
Un véritable traumatisme,
qui condamne le dirigeable
pour longtemps.
L'avion a gagné cette
bataille au XXᵉ siècle.
L'avion triomphe ! Le plus lourd que l'air
triomphe indiscutablement au XXᵉ siècle.
Nous sommes un certain nombre à penser
que le XXIᵉ siècle, notre siècle,
verra le triomphe
des dirigeables.
Le grand retour des dirigeables
serait-il dans l'air du temps ?
Avec la nécessité de créer
des moyens de transport écologiques,
les progrès de la science
et l'éternelle rêvent de voler,
de plus en plus de chercheurs
et d'entrepreneurs,
voient on ces géants des airs,
une solution tournée vers le futur.
Aujourd'hui la seule machine que sait
concevoir et fabriquer l'homme,
qui permet de perdurer dans les airs,
de se déplacer dans les airs
et de s'arrêter dans les airs,
c'est le ballon dirigeable. C'est l'unique
machine que sait construire l'homme.
Le dirigeable se pose à la verticale,
là où vous voulez précisément aller.
C'est un avantage énorme
par rapport aux avions,
car ils leur faut une piste.
Et puis l'hélicoptère, 200 kilomètres
et il n'a plus d'essence.
Le dirigeable n'a pas de limites.
Aujourd'hui, les matériaux ont évolué.
On ne vole plus à l'hydrogène mais
à l'hélium, la sécurité est présente.
Les tissus ont des performances qui sont
insensées aujourd'hui, qui sont colossales.
On arrive à des résistances gigantesques.
Ça, il y a 100 ans, on ne l'avait pas,
on n'avait pas ces moyens, ces matériaux,
on n'avait pas ces logiciels
prodigieux qu'on a aujourd'hui.
Le dirigeable a toutes les raisons
techniques de revenir aujourd'hui.
La première, pour moi,
c'est une raison écologique.
C'est probablement l'engin volant qui
consommera le moins pour soulever le plus.
Mon intime conviction :
ces machines sont extraordinaires,
elles peuvent réaliser des missions,
qu'aucune autre machine ne peut faire.
Si vous pouvez voler pendant un mois.
Vous imaginez la puissance de la chose.
Vous partez et pendant un mois,
vous n'allez pas remettre le pied sur terre.
Ce serait merveilleux. Pendant un mois
vous vivez dans les airs. C'est génial !
Tous les indicateurs sont au vert,
pour que le dirigeable reprenne sa place
dans le ciel et dans notre quotidien.
De nombreux jeunes entreprises
parient sur son avenir, comme ici,
dans ces hangars du sud de la France.
La NSE développe des systèmes
de surveillance et d'observation.
Baptiste REGAS, le directeur
de l'entreprise,
nous montre les tout derniers dirigeables
conçus par ses équipes.
C'est du bon boulot.
C'est un appareil qui va qui va
être livré la semaine prochaine,
pour les pompiers de Paris.
L'appareil sera équipé d'une caméra
gyro-stabilisée, couleur infrarouge,
et il sera utilisé pour avoir
une vision globale de la situation tactique,
lors de grands événements.
Un des derniers projets
est ce ballon dirigeable.
C'est un ballon dirigeable
de 1200 mètres cube destiné,
à des missions de prospection
pétrolière en Russie.
L'appareil est composé d'une
enveloppe qui fait 40 m de long,
1200 mètres cubes et d'une nacelle
qui peut accueillir jusqu'à 4 personnes,
équipé de deux moteurs
de 60 chevaux chacun.
L'appareil est en cours d'assemblage.
Ici il y aura deux sièges avec l'écran
de pilotage qui va se trouver ici.
Les deux moteurs ont un système de
vectorisation de la poussée des moteurs.
Le gros avantage d'utiliser
un ballon dirigeable,
pour des missions
de prospection pétrolière,
c'est d'utiliser
la stabilité de la machine.
Un ballon dirigeable flotte dans l'air,
il est donc très stable,
et beaucoup moins sujet
aux turbulences météorologiques.
Cette stabilité augmente
les performances de radar,
et permet d'aller voir plus loin
avec une meilleure précision,
sous le sous le sol.
Autonomie, stabilité, lenteur,
le ballon aurait toutes les qualités
requises pour mener parfaitement,
les missions de surveillance.
Sur celui ci, on fixe des outils
à la pointe de la technologie.
Ça, c'est une caméra,
couleur infrarouge,
full HD en couleur
qui est gyro-stabilisée,
Elle compense en permanence les mouvements
du ballon et la caméra reste stable,
ce qui assure des missions
de surveillance de jour comme de nuit,
d'un site industriel par exemple
ou d'une frontière.
La caméra est intégrée sur
la nacelle qui se trouve ici.
La nacelle est intégrée sous l'enveloppe
accrochée sous l'enveloppe du ballon dirigeable,
et le ballon dirigeable évolue
en effectuant sa mission,
contrôlé depuis le sol à distance.
Si vous voulez vous arrêter en l'air,
effectuer des vols stationnaire
ou à très faible vitesse,
c'est tout à fait possible.
Aujourd'hui,
le marché est sur la surveillance.
C'est le seul marché
qui est assez mûr et qui nécessite,
d'assurer une permanence
de la mission sur la zone,
et le ballon dirigeable et intrinsèquement
extrêmement bien adapté,
pour réaliser ce type de mission.
Car il a une grande autonomie de vol.
On a fait des progrès absolument
prodigieux avec tout ce qui est,
observation, capteur,
capture de données.
On fait des choses
prodigieuses aujourd'hui,
on peut tout voir, tout enregistrer...
Donc le marché
de la surveillance est énorme.
La société a été créée il y a 7 ans, il
n'y avait pas de ballon qui évoluait en France.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des ballons
à NSE qui sont utilisés par des civils,
et par des policiers et avant la fin de
l'année, par des militaires en France.
On n'est pas dans la science
fiction, on est dans le réel.
Aujourd'hui, nos ballons équipés des
capteurs les plus performants évoluent entre,
1000 mètres au dessus du sol
jusqu'à 3000 mètres,
et les capteurs permettent de détecter,
un être humain jusqu'à 40 km maximum,
dans le champ visuel, avec des caméras
et un véhicule jusqu'à 80 km.
Et ce type de plateforme est aujourd'hui
un des moyens les plus adaptés,
et les plus économiques pour assurer
cette permanence sur zone.
Les qualités des dirigeables
dans les missions de surveillance,
ne datent pas d'aujourd'hui.
Dès la Première Guerre mondiale,
on l'a vu,
les ballons sont utilisés sur le front
pour repérer les lignes ennemies.
Et même pour prévenir
la marine en cas d'attaque.
Ils rendent des services absolument
prodigieux. Ils détectent les sous-marins.
Quand on est à la surface
de l'eau avec un bateau,
on ne voit pas au fond, il y a
un reflet sur la surface,
et on ne peut pas voir
ce qu'il y a en dessous.
Quand vous êtes dans une machine qui
est en l'air, un dirigeable ou un avion
vous voyez très bien
ce qu'il y a en dessous.
Vous voyez les sous marins.
Les dirigeables,
dès la Première Guerre mondiale,
ont rendu d'énormes services
en détection sous-marine.
Avec 14-18, l'aéronautique
entre dans la guerre.
Stimulée, l'aviation fait alors
un bond en avant considérable.
Mais les dirigeables aussi.
Leur stabilité dans les airs est telle,
que l'armée les utilise
pour lancer des obus.
Les Allemands bombardent la ville
de Liège avec des zeppelins.
Ça crée l'épouvante.
Les machines de 200 m de long au dessus
de la ville qui lâchent des bombes,
On n'avait jamais vu ça.
C'est l'épouvante !
Un siècle plus tard,
les qualités de stabilité,
de précision et d'observation
des dirigeables,
sont toujours reconnues
mais leur mission a évolué.
En Allemagne, à Friedrichshafen,
le fief de la firme Zeppelin,
le dirigeable connaît depuis
20 ans une deuxième jeunesse.
3 fois moins long que leurs
illustres prédécesseurs,
ces zeppelins semi-rigides de 80 mètres
sont essentiellement réservés,
à des vols touristiques
au dessus du lac de Constance.
Mais depuis quelques années,
Thomas Brandt, le directeur de la firme,
est de plus en plus sollicité
pour que ses zeppelins,
participent à des missions d'observation.
Nous sommes sur une plateforme
technologique unique,
parce que nous pouvons voler
de façon tranquille, sans vibration,
et assez longtemps de façon stationnaire.
Et c'est ce qui permet de prendre
des mesures environnementales,
qu'aucun autre aéronef
n'est capable de faire.
L'an dernier, le dirigeable était,
quasiment devenu un laboratoire
volant pour étudier l'atmosphère.
L'air était aspiré puis aussitôt décomposé
pour analyser les éléments chimiques,
à différentes altitudes
de 100 à 2000 mètres.
Je crois me souvenir qu'une douzaine
d'universités internationales,
ont participé à cette étude.
Un zeppelin nouvelle génération a même
été missionné pour survoler Paris,
afin de réaliser des relevés utiles
pour la sécurité de la capitale.
Oliver Jäger était aux commandes.
Nous avons eu la possibilité
et le privilège de voler au dessus de Paris,
à 80 mètres de hauteur,
pour faire une sorte de carte
des radiations de la ville.
Nous avons reçu cet ordre du gouvernement
français, des militaires,
pour qu'ils aient des données de base,
qui permettent de lutter contre
d'éventuelles attaques terroristes.
Retour en France, près de Cannes, chez
le fabricant de satellites Thales,
un pool de chercheurs est en train
de mettre au point un dirigeable nouveau.
Nom de code : Stratobus.
Là aussi, il s'agit de mettre
des yeux dans le ciel,
mais cette fois à très haute altitude.
Jean-philippe Chessel
supervise cette mission.
Tout le monde rêve de prendre
un peu de hauteur,
et de pouvoir observer ce qui se passe
un peu plus loin que devant son jardin.
Et pour ça, il faut monter en altitude.
Et donc la stratosphère,
c'est un moyen de le faire.
Dans la stratosphère,
à 20 000 mètres d'altitude,
entièrement télécommandée,
autonome en énergie grâce
à des capteurs solaires,
ce dirigeable pourrait réaliser ou compléter
les mêmes missions qu'un satellite.
Pour envoyer une station là-haut, il faut
signer un chèque de 60 millionsd'euros.
Pour une fusée ça coute
minimum 60 millionsd'euros.
Alors qu'une station stratosphérique
qui serait un dirigeable,
Elle monte toute seule.
Si jamais il y a une panne
et qu'on veut faire quelque chose,
elle va descendre tout seul. Tandis
qu'un satellite ne redescend pas.
Reste que le défi technologique
est gigantesque.
Le problème des ballons et des dirigeables,
c'est que le gaz porteur,
va prendre du volume,
au fur et à mesure qu'il monte
dans l'atmosphère,
parce que la densité d'air externe
est plus faible, donc il va s'étendre.
Ce qui est plus compliqué
dans la stratosphère,
c'est que l'air est moins dense,
l'air porte moins.
Il faut des volumes
plus grands pour porter.
Et également, on peut
emporter moins de masse.
Il faut y arriver à la stratosphère.
Si je prends l'exemple du stratobus,
ce volume là,
c'est 60 000 mètres cubes,
Quand il est à 20 km,
au sol, à l'intérieur,
on va mettre une poche de gaz porteur,
qui ne fera que 6000 mètres cubes.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans le reste de l'enveloppe ?
Il y a de l'air et cet air,
oblige le stratobus,
à rester au sol.
Donc si on veut le faire monter,
on échappe cet air.
Et au fur et à mesure
que l'air s'échappe,
le gaz porteur qui
est à l'intérieur s'étend,
et va remplir tout
le volume du stratobus.
Et ainsi, quand on arrive à 20 km,
il n'y a plus que du gaz porteur.
De l'hélium en l'occurrence.
Quand Thales nous à parler de ça,
je trouvais le projet formidable.
C'était un peu du Jules Verne,
et je me disais c'est formidable,
mais techniquement,
il y a des verrous technologiques,
ce n'est pas gagné.
Ce sera une grande première
mondiale car,
un certain nombre d'Etats se sont brûler
les ailes à essayer ce genre de choses,
les américains entre autres.
Je crois que le projet est mûr.
On travaille avec eux depuis
pratiquement un an.
Là, j'y crois beaucoup plus.
Les Américains sont montés à peu près
à 18-19 km, mais ils n'y ont pas tenu.
Le problème, c'est d'arriver
à tenir suffisamment longtemps.
Ils ont tenu quelques heures
et ils sont redescendus.
Les Chinois sont montés, ils ont tenu
24 h et ils sont redescendus.
Donc l'enjeu n'est pas que
de monter à 20 km d'altitude,
c'est aussi d'arriver à rester
plus d'un jour, plus de deux jours,
une semaine, des semaines,
voire un an.
L'enjeu, c'est ça. On n'a pas
inventé le dirigeable stratosphérique,
ce qu'on a inventé, c'est la manière
d'avoir assez d'énergie,
pour pouvoir rester stationnaire
dans la stratosphère,
pour des vents qui
sont des vents de 90 km/h.
C'est ça l'idée et l'innovation
principale du stratobus,
elle est là.
C'est vraiment une guerre
terrible contre le poids,
et contre ce problème de masse.
C'est être plus léger que l'air
et l'être à 20 km d'altitude.
Une course contre la montre est engagée
pour remporter le marché.
Le Stratosbus est plutôt bien
placé dans cette conquête du ciel.
Avec un lancement prévu en 2020.
Il y a un défi, la forme du stratobus,
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle forme,
c'est une forme qui doit
être très aérodynamique.
Le souci, c'est qu'on a les panneaux
solaires sur le dessus du ballon,
et qu'on doit suivre le soleil
donc on a un mouvement de roulis.
Si on a une forme aplatie
comme une forme de raie,
si on s'incline sur le côté,
on se met à tourner.
Le but est de rester
stationnaire sur un seul point,
il faut que quand on tourne, il n'y ait
pas de changement aérodynamique.
La rotation, c'est juste
pour le suivi du soleil.
Ce qui est assez étonnant
avec les dirigeables,
c'est que nos anciens, qui dans
les années 30, faisaient les ballons,
ils avaient déjà bien étudié les sujets
et avec nos outils numériques,
on a regardé des formes optimisées,
on a cherché d'autres profils,
et finalement ce sont ces formes là qui
sont quand même intéressantes à utiliser.
La forme oblongue est considérée
comme la plus stable.
Il y a 100 ans, les dirigeables qui partaient
à la conquête de nouveaux territoires,
étaient déjà comme cela.
En 1926, c'est avec ce dirigeable
de 106 mètres de long,
que le héros norvégien Roald Amundsen,
réussit le premier survol du pôle Nord.
Les dirigeables incarnent alors
le champ de tous les possibles.
Surtout le L7 127 apparu en 1928,
huit ans avant l'Hindenburg.
Ce zeppelin symbolise à lui seul
l'âge d'or des dirigeables.
Clairement, le plus beau
des ballons  dirigeables,
qui a toutes les lettres
de noblesse des ballons,
c'est le LZ 127, le Graf Zeppelin.
Surtout, le LZ 127 a fait
le tour du monde en 1929.
Tout le voyage
a été financé par Hearst,
le roi des journaux,
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le trajet a dû commencer en Amérique.
Pour la première fois, un aéronef
tente de boucler le tour du monde.
4 étapes sont prévues pour le LZ 127,
appelé aussi le Graf Zeppelin.
Friedrichshafen, Tokyo, Los Angeles
et retour à New-York.
Le patron de la firme Zeppelin,
HugoEckener,
participe à ce voyage vers l'inconnu.
La tension est palpable.
À bord, il y a 25 passagers
et 35 hommes d'équipage.
Il traverse toute la Sibérie, il va
au Japon avec l'autorisation de Staline,
qui n'était pas forcément
bien disposé à l'époque.
Mais là, c'était tellement extraordinaire
que Staline a dit oui, il faut faire ça.
Oui, avec ces dirigeables, on arrivait
à atteindre des régions où avant,
jamais on aurait pu aller.
Le survole durant 4 jours au dessus
de la Sibérie était risqué,
et représentait une aventure.
Les passagers ne se sentaient
pas tout à fait à l'aise.
C'est ce que l'on peut lire
dans leurs rapports. Ils se disaient :
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si on s'écrase
au milieu de ces contrées sauvages ?
Dix jours après avoir quitté
New York, le Graf Zeppelin,
atteint enfin le pays du soleil levant.
Il y a eu une grande réception,
car c'était la première fois
qu'un dirigeable atterrissait à Tokyo.
Vous imaginez, ils étaient
depuis 111 h en vol,
et c'était une traversée
d'environ 14000 km.
Il faut s'imaginer ça.
C'est une performance que
l'on a pu réaliser en avion,
que bien des décennies plus tard.
Tokyo-Los Angeles,
puis Los Angeles-New York.
Les héros réussissent ce premier tour
du monde après 12 jours de vol,
et 21 jours de voyage.
On les célébrait comme des stars,
si on peut dire.
Les membres d'équipage,
mais aussi les passagers.
Le summum a été leur retour à New York.
Il est accueilli
par une foule en délire.
Il y avait un engouement,
un enthousiasme pour ces choses.
C'était une période extraordinaire.
HugoEckener est porté en triomphe.
Son Graf Zeppelin
battra tous les records.
En neuf ans d'exploitation, il a
embarqué plus de 13 000 privilégiés,
traversé 143 fois l'Atlantique,
et parcouru plus d'un million
et demi de kilomètres.
C'est une machine qui était complètement
aboutie, qui a une carrière,
sans incident ou accident
et qui a fini démonté.
Mais c'était LE ballon dirigeable.
On va revenir à tout ça.
On y reviendra, ça c'est sûr.
Explorer de nouveaux territoires.
Aller toujours plus haut, plus loin.
Les défis des années 30
sont toujours d'actualité.
Comme celui d'embarquer des charges
toujours plus lourdes dans les dirigeables.
Dans l'entre deux guerres,
l'armée américaine envisageait,
d'en faire des porte avions.
Six avions entraient
dans le ventre du géant.
Aujourd'hui, l'idée de transporter
revient en force.
Pour transporter
des charges très lourdes,
dans des endroits très difficiles d'accès,
sans besoin d'infrastructures,
tout le monde pense aux dirigeables.
Transporter des colis très lourds
et denses à terre, ça défonce les routes.
C'est un vrai problème. Il faut des routes
très larges. C'est très compliqué.
C'est un marché effectivement,
qui un jour explosera,
car ça coûtera beaucoup moins cher
de transporter avec des dirigeables,
que de transporter à terre.
Parce qu'un dirigeable peut se poser
et décoller d'à peu près n'importe où,
Différents projets émergent pour
en faire de véritables grues volantes.
Des dirigeables d'un genre nouveau,
des dirigeables qui utilisent
la portance d'un ballon,
et la force aérodynamique d'un avion.
Dans le jargon des aéronautes,
on appelle cela des hybrides.
En France, à Moulins, dans l'Allier,
c'est ce marché que vise cette équipe
d'ingénieurs de l'entreprise Voliris.
Sous la houlette de son fondateur,
Alain Bernard.
C'est une machine qu'on livre
en container à un endroit.
On assemble sur place, donc
on sort la bâche de son container,
on la gonfle, on met tout ce matériel
à l'intérieur en l'ayant gonflé à l'air,
et après ça, on accroche la nacelle
en dessous et c'est fait.
Comme un drone géant,
ce dirigeable commandé à distance,
est conçu pour soulever 30 tonnes,
et déplacer sa charge sur
des centaines de kilomètres.
Sans qu'il y ait besoin
d'installation aéroportuaire.
L'Algérie serait intéressée
par ce projet,
pour désenclaver certaines
de ces régions désertiques.
Aujourd'hui, Voliris fait des
tests sur un prototype miniature,
avant de réaliser
une version grandeur nature.
On a fait une maquette à un septième
de ce qu'on veut faire.
On est dans quelque chose
qui fait un quart.
et donc on veut passer
à la grande échelle
pour avoir plus de portance.
Pour y parvenir, ces ingénieurs doivent
d'abord relever un défi de taille,
les lois de la pesanteur.
Ce que l'on ne sait pas faire
en aérostatique,
c'est poser une charge puisqu'on
est en équilibre dans l'air,
et ne pas être propulsé vers le ciel,
avec une force égale à cette charge.
Quand vous montez dans un zeppelin,
on fait monter 2 personnes,
on en fait descendre 2,
pour maintenir l'équilibre avec les
quelques sacs de sable,
qu'on a pu mettre au moment où
on fait le transport de passagers.
Si vous posez un container de 30 tonnes,
vous êtes propulsé vers le ciel,
avec une force de 30 tonnes, c'est à dire
la poussée de la fusée Ariane.
Ça se termine dans la stratosphère.
Votre ballon qui ne peut pas monter
aussi haut parce qu'à ce moment là,
il se dilate trop
et sa tire sur la toile,
va exploser dans l'atmosphère.
Les lois de la pesanteur,
un véritable casse tête qui dure
depuis les débuts de l'aérostation,
et de ces héros téméraires.
Être à la fois plus léger
que l'air et manœuvrable.
Tel est le challenge qu'il faut relever
en trouvant le bon équilibre,
entre portance, poids et puissance.
Et si la technologie
et les matériaux ont progressé,
les règles de la physique,
elles, sont immuables.
Pour Alain Bernard et son équipe,
il va falloir déjouer toutes
ces contraintes pour mettre au point,
le futur grand dirigeable capable
de porter des charges importantes.
Mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
à travailler sur des prototypes.
Des projets encore plus ambitieux se
développent ailleurs, comme à Los Angeles,
où l'armée américaine a investi 45 millions
de dollars dans le Dragon Dream.
Ce dirigeable, fusion entre l'avion cargo,
l'hélicoptère et la soucoupe volante,
pourrait transporter
60 tonnes de matériel,
à la vitesse de 200 km/h.
Après ses premiers tests réalisés en 2014,
le projet est en attente.
De l'autre côté de la planète,
en Russie, les projets de dirigeables
destinés au fret se multiplient.
Les Russes aussi imaginent le futur
avec un ciel bien différent.
Mais c'est en Angleterre, à Cardington,
dans ces hangars datant
de la Première Guerre mondiale,
que le concept de dirigeables cargo
pour charge lourde semble le mieux avancé.
Son enveloppe ultra résistante
mesure 92 mètres,
et aurait la capacité
de transporter 50 tonnes.
Le marché pour de telles machines
serait considérable,
si l'on en croit la publicité réalisée par
le constructeur de l'aéronef anglais.
Une analyse à récemment évalué
à 50 milliardsde livres,
le chiffre d'affaires généré par le marché
des dirigeables dans les 20 prochaines années,
soit 500 aéronefs d'ici 2036.
Voici Airlander.
Une machine volante vraiment
écologique et économique.
Écologique et économique,
le Airlander peaufine encore sa sortie,
car sa technologie
n'est pas complètement au point.
Reste à résoudre plusieurs problèmes,
comme la prise au vent et le pilotage.
Cela paraît anodin et pourtant.
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est qu'on est aussi léger que l'air.
On est sur une très grosse machine,
très légère,
et donc ça induit
beaucoup de contraintes.
Depuis toujours, le vent est bien
l'ennemi numéro un du dirigeable,
surtout pour les phases
d'atterrissage et de décollage.
Pour faire voler ces dirigeables, il avait
besoin d'une équipe au sol phénoménale.
On évoque des centaines de personnes pour
tenir un zeppelin qui arrive ou qui s'en va.
Ces gens là, attendait que
le dirigeable veuille bien se poser,
que les conditions soient bonnes. Vous
vous rendez compte de l'organisation ?
Aujourd'hui, on sait très bien
que 200 personnes au sol,
ce serait tellement phénoménal en prix
que le voyage serait inabordable.
Tous les ballons
qui volent aujourd'hui,
ont besoin de personnel au sol.
Et lorsqu'il y a un peu d'air dehors,
il y a toujours besoin
de 5, 10, 15 personnes au sol.
C'est complètement archaïque.
Le commandant arrive près du sol,
il jette des cordes, les personnes
courent, prennent les cordes,
et utilisent leur corps comme masse
pour freiner le ballon, le stabiliser,
et l'orienter par rapport au vent.
Gérer le vent,
les moteurs, le poids,
le pilotage reste l'autre
problématique du dirigeable.
Avant, dans les grands dirigeables,
il y avait des barres à roue.
Il y avait 2 pilotes,
un dans le sens longitudinal,
qui faisait la barre
à roue de la profondeur,
et un deuxième qui le pilotait
qui était dans l'autre sens.
Il y avait des commandes
à l'arrière, de direction,
il y avait des ballonnets, on pouvait
relâcher du gaz dans certains cas,
on pouvait au contraire lâcher du lest.
C'était compliqué. C'est pour ça
qu'il y avait 40 personnes d'équipage.
Sur l'Hinderburg, c'est 40 ou 35
personnes d'équipage,
pour faire marcher la machine.
Aujourd'hui, la nouvelle génération
de zeppelins a été conçue,
pour être manœuvrable
par un seul pilote.
Avec une simple manette mais
pour le reste, cela se complique.
Nous pilotons et dirigeons
le zeppelin avec ce joystick.
Ici, nous avons aussi des instruments
pour la navigation et pour l'orientation.
Au milieu, nous avons ces commandes
qui permettent d'utiliser,
si on le souhaite,
chaque moteur séparément.
En haut, on trouve les leviers bleus,
qui servent à faire entrer
ou sortir de l'air des ballonnets,
et les leviers rouges qui servent
à gérer le gaz porteur, l'hélium.
Vous faites le compte,
vous avez déjà douze commandes.
Il faut faire tout ça en même temps.
Pendant que le vent
est variable et vous remue.
Ce qui est particulier
dans le ballon,
c'est qu'entre le moment
où vous exercez une commande,
et le moment où cette commande
a un effet, parfois c'est immédiat,
parfois, ça peut prendre 4 secondes.
Et 4 secondes, quand vous vous
rapprochez du sol ou d'un bâtiment,
c'est très long.
Il faut être 100% concentré.
C'est vrai.
Il faut penser à beaucoup
de choses en même temps.
Il faut simplifier tout ça.
Maîtriser la maniabilité, faire en sorte que
le dirigeable puisse voler par tout temps.
Mais tous ces verrous technologiques
sont peu à peu en train d'être levés.
Des ballons qui s'étendent tout seul
en fonction de la dilatation de l'hélium,
des structures de plus en plus légères,
et des moteurs de plus en plus
puissants et automatisés.
Le Hindenburg volait à 100 km/h.
Aujourd'hui, un dirigeable pourrait
atteindre 200 km/h.
Après un siècle de recherches, voici le
dirigeable du futur selon Philippe Tixier.
Un ballon à structure rigide avec un
fond plat pour éliminer les dépressions,
lors des phases d'envol et d'atterrissage.
Cet ingénieur a conceptualisé
lui-même ce prototype,
récompensé en France par le Prix
de l'innovation en 2011 au Bourget.
Ce démonstrateur DS 06,
complètement terminé avec
tous ses équipements à bord,
en état de voler.
Il ne pèse que 1200 grammes.
Il ne fait que deux mètres de long.
1200 grammes, ce n'est rien !
Une légèreté prodigieuse.
Si vous vous montez dessus,
il ne bouge pas.
Il est rigide.
Celui qui est là-bas,
à vide, il ne pèse que 1800 kilos.
50 mètres de long.
Ce n'est rien. C'est du vide.
Et pourtant, il résiste
aux efforts énormes du vent.
C'est fou !
C'est ça le challenge.
Mais il faut que ça tienne.
Aujourd'hui on est en passe
et les savoir faire sont là,
d'avoir des dirigeables capables
de se poser avec presque personne au sol.
De décoller, de faire son travail,
de revenir et d'être quasiment autonome.
Donc ça c'est nouveau. Dans le modèle
économique, ce serait nécessaire.
Le ballon dirigeable est tellement
maniable qu'on peut réaliser,
une sorte de voltige
avec des ballons dirigeables.
J'en ai moi-même fait.
Le ballon est arrêté,
commence la démonstration,
on met les gaz à fond
et en à peine 4 secondes,
vous cabrez à 45 degrés.
L'appareil monte, il s'arrête, vous piquer
à plus de 50 degrés et arrivé proche du sol,
à remonter, vous vous arrêtez
à nouveau, vous reculez.
C'est absolument merveilleux.
Et ça, ce n'est possible uniquement,
parce que les technologies
actuelles le permettent.
Le grand retour des dirigeables est
en train de devenir réalité.
En France dans les Bouches du Rhône,
un projet de grande ampleur se prépare,
à l'abri des regards.
André Soulage supervise
la création d'une technopôle,
une sorte de village dédié
à l'industrie des plus léger que l'air.
Ce hangar va accueillir les premiers
démonstrateurs du plan industriel dirigeables.
Et c'est ici, dans ce hangar,
que va naître la filière industrielle
dirigeable française.
Dans 2 ans, des gens seront en train
de monter des ballons dirigeables.
Et dans 10 ans, vous aurez une usine
de production de pièces de dirigeables,
qui alimentera les gros
hangars situés à côtés.
On voit naître plein d'idées,
plein de projets partout.
À un moment donné, ça donnera quelque
chose de positif et d'intéressant.
Les plus belles choses en ballon
dirigeable ont été faites il y a longtemps.
Le dirigeable,
c'est l'éloge de la lenteur.
Un moyen de transport unique
et irremplaçable.
Voilà sans doute pourquoi, tous sont
convaincus que son retour est inéluctable.
On ne fait rien de plus triste finalement
que les voyages modernes en avion,
où vous êtes au dessus des nuages, vous
ne voyez rien, il n'y a pas de perspective.
C'est la chance du dirigeable
car avec un dirigeable,
vous volez à 300 mètres
de hauteur sur un paysage,
où vous pouvez même voir
des cygnes sur un lac.
Moi, je vois un très grand avenir
des dirigeables dans le tourisme.
C'est un autre univers. Le ballon
dirigeable, c'est un bateau dans l'air,
et il a toute la poésie
du bateau dans le ciel.
Un dirigeable, vous n'entendez rien.
Vous êtes dans le silence.
La grande différence, c'est la vue.
La vue que l'on a depuis cette cabine,
on ne l'a dans aucun avion
et même dans aucun hélicoptère.
Mon rêve est de fabriquer une machine
et je sais qu'on a les compétences,
pour fabriquer ce type de machine
qui peut emporter 40, 50 personnes,
pendant un mois en l'air.
Imaginez, vous survoler toute
l'Afrique à faible altitude.
Vous redécouvrez complètement
la manière de visiter des pays.
Je pense que dans 5 à 10 ans, on commencera
à revoir des dirigeables dans le ciel.
Des petits formats,
des moyens, des plus grands.
Il y a un monde merveilleux
qui s'ouvre à nous.
Ce monde là, va être bardé
de nouveaux métiers,
et les jeunes vont s'y intéresser,
s'y passionner. C'est le futur.
Ça semble une rétro innovation, mais
pour moi, c'est vraiment le futur.
Des dirigeables miniatures,
des grues volantes,
des ballons stratosphériques
et des vaisseaux aériens.
Finalement, quand au XIXᵉ siècle,
le Jules Verne du dessin Albert Robida,
imaginait le ciel du 20ᵉ,
il ne se trompait pas beaucoup.
Juste d'un siècle.